hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown president biden
holding meetings with moderate and
progressive democrats urging them to
come together on his build back better
agenda which includes a 3.5 trillion
dollar budget plan and a one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill iowa
congresswoman ashley hinson a member of
the house budget committee shares her
thoughts on the budget battle
president biden facing scrutiny from
lawmakers on both sides of the aisle
over how his administration is
addressing thousands of haitian migrants
gathering at the u.s mexico border
looking to find refuge in the u.s fox
news sunday host chris wallace breaks
down the situation at the southern
border and weighs in on the president's
approval rating hitting a new low plus
commentary by jimmy fayla host of fox
across america the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
i'm ashley webster i'm kennedy i'm jason
chaffetz and this is the fox news
rundown
friday september 24th 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal another government shutdown is
possible and some officials are warning
one could mean a delay in social
security child care tax credit and food
stamp payments you have a president you
have the senate and you have congress in
democrat control and they are driving
the agenda right now when their agenda
is to max out that credit card all the
way through next year
i'm dave anthony it's the newest border
controversy this time over haitian
migrants and it has president biden
facing critics on both sides i can
probably a majority of the country is
saying you can't let
thousands of people many of whom may
have coveted
come across the border and settle in our
country on the other hand you have
people on the left wing of the
democratic party saying you're acting
too much like trump when you close the
border and i'm jimmy fella i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
the white house has told government
agencies to prepare for a possible
government shutdown congress needs to
raise the debt ceiling by september 30th
the house passed a continuing resolution
to do that but republicans have said
they will block it in the senate white
house spokeswoman jen saki said thursday
we are taking every step we can to
mitigate the impacts of a potential
shutdown on our pandemic response
economic recovery or other priorities
treasury secretary janet yellen warned
that without a vote to raise the debt
limit food stamps social security checks
and payments to members of the military
may temporarily stop senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell said last week no
republican will vote to raise the debt
limit in this way because of democrats
insistence on a 3.5 trillion dollar
spending plan i've never seen such
an effort to expand the reach
of the federal government
like we've been confronted with this
year so he said it's democrats
responsibility and they should raise the
debt limit through reconciliation like
they are doing with their large spending
plan this week the president met with
several democrats including moderate
ones to talk about that spending plan as
some have balked at the price tag senate
majority leader chuck schumer and house
speaker nancy pelosi though said
thursday the white house
the house
and the senate
have reached agreement on a framework
that will pay for any final negotiated
agreement
what does that mean that means we're
proceeding that we've made great
progress and we're proceeding but some
progressives in the democratic party
have said they won't go for the smaller
trillion dollar infrastructure package
without the larger one passing as well
so house minority leader kevin mccarthy
says he won't vote for even the smaller
package now and he's telling house
republicans to do the same white house
spokeswoman jen saki said the republican
reasoning here for not voting to raise
the debt ceiling is disingenuous they
are playing with the faith and credit of
the united states treasury this is not a
game to the president this is
our economy this is not about
partisanship but some republicans say
spending trillions of dollars is no game
either speaker pelosi and the democrats
in congress have drawn their line in the
sand ashley henson is a republican
congresswoman from iowa and we know
that's the bill that they passed which
was completely partisan and how they
went about that approach this week it's
dead on arrival in the senate and we
know that so i'm hopeful that they will
come to the table we know that there's
been quite a few meetings between you
know our leadership and their leadership
obviously and between their leadership
in the white house about what that
direction looks like and so so i'm
hopeful we don't go that path but they
need to be responsible they need to
understand that you know republicans are
not going to continue to support running
up our credit card our credit card's
already maxed out and they're acting
like they have a blank checkbook and so
if they want to extend that debt ceiling
until next december which is what they
have have done in essence in what we
passed um that's just not responsible it
disrespects taxpayers hard-earned
dollars and we need to operate our
government in reality not like we're
playing a game of monopoly yeah i heard
the the sentiment order mcconnell has
said he'll he'll go for like a
standalone bill on natural disaster
relief and other items but not something
tied to raising the debt ceiling and
that republicans have said that
democrats should just go ahead with this
debt ceiling issue through
reconciliation much in the same way that
they're dealing with this 3.5 trillion
dollar package which we don't even know
if that's the real number yet but
democrats say they literally can't do
this due to parliamentary rules and
procedure they they can't raise the debt
ceiling in the same package
where does this end if they would be
willing to to back off that package and
just say hey we're gonna be realistic
here hit the pause button as senator
manchin said we needed to do and we know
again um the senate obviously is not on
board with this package either so um at
this point i think they're just wasting
everybody everybody's time
taxpayer dollars in the process and then
the process clearly is broken and they
need to
see reality here they they have to own
this
democrats counter this by saying look
republicans you guys passed a big tax
cut and voted to raise the debt ceiling
during the trump years also without any
move to reduce the debt so why can't you
do that now what do you say to that
yeah well again this is about them
pushing forward with a three and a half
trillion dollar spending package um you
know we in and obviously i just i'm new
here i've been here nine months and um
in the past though our conference has
supported responsible uh measures for
the government tax cuts and jobs act it
unleashed an economy like we had never
seen before i've talked to dozens of
small businesses in my district that
had
great success and and saw that success
obviously kind of stalled out when the
pandemic hit and nobody could foresee
that coming but ultimately those were
the responsible decisions to make at the
time but we were not facing this triple
threat of government right where you
have a president you have the senate and
you have congress in democrat control
and they are driving the agenda right
now when their agenda is to max out that
credit card all the way through next
year so again this goes back to what's
responsible sending that deadline all
the way until after the election next
year in december of 2022 is not
responsible and again that's why you're
not going to see republican support for
this approach to raising the debt
ceiling what will
republicans support because we're
hearing some pretty ominous warnings
about if the debt ceiling isn't raised
and these are to pay previous debts this
isn't prospective funding this is
hindsight payments that we're making
things we've already spent money on
and we've heard the treasury secretary
and others say if you guys don't raise
the debt ceiling we're talking about
social security checks not going out
people who rely on food stamps will be
in a bind i mean this sounds pretty
disastrous regardless of the finger
pointing and the blame what's how do we
move forward here so that doesn't happen
yeah well the democrats have to get to
218 votes again as i said they have the
gavel in the house and um
if they continue again this process of
moving forward with three and a half
trillion dollars of spending not to
mention again for for me the real kicker
here is how long they've chosen to
extend that deadline we don't know what
they're going to do next year we know
that we have a three and a half trillion
dollar spending package on the table in
addition an infrastructure bill with a
over trillion dollar price tag not to
mention the spending that we had earlier
this year and who knows what is coming
next we've heard from
several members of the progressive
caucus that three and a half trillion
dollars is the floor of what they want
to spend in a time when the office of
management and budget is telling us that
they didn't even account for any
inflation in their budgetary projections
for the regular budget that they
presented to the budget committee which
i serve on
and those targets were not allowed to
move forward through the regular process
for any of that appropriations process
so i think that again what i'm asking
for is a reality check for the democrats
in congress and they need to
take responsibility come to center and
and do what's right here which in my
mind is backing off this spending
package
and briefly if the continuing resolution
to fund the government were to come back
to the house without without a debt
limit provision
would would you guys support it would
republicans support it it sounds like
mitch mcconnell has said he he might
support that
i think if you saw a stand-alone
continuing resolution i think that is
something that would gain republican
support i know i would definitely look
at that i've heard i don't want to
commit until i see it obviously because
ultimately we've also heard there are
some possible changes to the cr so i
want to make sure that ultimately if we
have those funding levels i think that's
a more appropriate level of funding for
for example the defense department for
homeland security not to mention
if we have the continuing resolution it
includes the the taxpayer protections of
the hyde amendment for example which we
know for the first time in 40 years
democrats in congress decided that they
wanted to take out those bipartisan
protections which ensure that taxpayer
dollars are not going to fund abortions
so i think you know ultimately for me
making sure we continue to fund
government is a priority but at the same
time you have to balance being
responsible and and the democrat party
is the majority party right now and so
they need to be responsible and and
figure out what's the next step to make
sure that this uh cliff doesn't happen
does the smaller trillion dollar
infrastructure package
that we've all been calling bipartisan
does that get derailed over all of this
because we know that the progressive
wing of the democratic party has said
they will not go for the
trillion dollar package until the 3.5
trillion one is good to go
and thursday house minority leader
mccarthy said their insistence that the
larger package pass as well means the
smaller package is no longer bipartisan
you can't call it that does this all
burn down here
well unfortunately again this comes back
to they are the ones driving this car
forward and what we've seen is that they
have
amongst themselves as you mentioned the
progressives who want to hold that bill
hostage but then you have others who
want to see that bill move forward and
aren't willing to support three and a
half trillion dollars of spending until
that happens so again they are
continuing to to have those
conversations and
again where my my frustration is is when
we were called back back in august to
vote on moving these policies forward
they didn't even have the votes to move
reconciliation forward and they made
they did a lot of backroom deals to make
it happen and they ended up having to
even pass that procedurally through a
rule to deem it as even being passed so
that committees could even work the
process has been broken from the start
but as far as infrastructure goes back
home iowans want targeted infrastructure
investment they want roads and bridges
locks and dams and broadband and those
are the top priorities that i've been
hearing about and talking about for
months and so i think if they were
willing to you know hit pause on those
large spending packages and do a more
targeted infrastructure investment
package you would see a lot of
republican support if they pared that
down and went with a continuing
resolution
and again backed off that three and a
half trillion dollar spending package
again i think you'd see more people
trying to to come to the table on our
side of the aisle
well it sounds like they are willing to
back off on the 3.5 trillion dollar
number for all of our talk of that
number because it even after the
president met with democrats this week
on thursday speaker pelosi and and
senate majority leader schumer said you
know this isn't about a dollar figure
right we don't want to commit to that we
want to we want to talk about what the
priority list of items is rather than a
dollar figure unfortunately though what
happened is that this was about the
dollar figure for them um we know that
that was again you have progressives
saying three and a half trillion dollars
is not enough and the way this entire
process went was they set that three and
a half trillion dollar number and then
went back to the policy committees and
said here fill it in so to me it's
evident that this process was broken
from the start and um you know when
you're talking about the biggest jump
towards socialism in our nation's
history that's what they wanted with
this bill puts government in control of
every aspect of our lives and
livelihoods and whether that's three and
a half trillion or five trillion i i
think that is the direction they have
made very clear that they want to move
finally congresswoman um the the house
in passing the the bill this week to
avoid the government shutdown also took
out funding for israel's iron dome for
those who don't know it's a defensive
system that intercepts rockets before
landing in israel and it's it's done a
tremendous job protecting civilians uh
pulling it out of the bill was
apparently to appease
the the so-called squad or people on the
further to the left of the party who
don't want it funded but it is now
democrats who don't agree with the squad
on this who introduced the standalone
bill to fund the iron dome
what do you what do you make of that is
that just division within their party or
does it speak to something larger about
the priorities of the democrats
yeah i think it is indicative of the
division within their party they took
that bill out because or that portion of
that funding out to fund the iron dome
because it was the only way they could
get their progressives on board to pass
that bill earlier this week and i think
it's unfortunate that they are truly
playing politics here um that chaos and
dysfunction in speakers pelosi's house
is on full display this week and that's
just one example um and the iron dome is
a purely defensive system israel is
using it to protect its citizens from
terrorist rockets we've seen them
under attack several times this year so
again this is about politics appeasing
that far left rather than standing with
our allies and i'm happy to vote for
that you know reallocation of those
dollars today a billion dollars to go to
israel i stand with israel i know iowans
stand with israel and republicans stand
with israel so i would venture to guess
you'll see overwhelming republican
support for it and you'll see democrats
who who won't support that funding and i
think that's indicative of the
progressive wing and that party
and their lack of understanding of how
crucial and ally like israel is to us in
the middle east congresswoman henson
thank you so much for your time thank
you for having me
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
it's a much smaller camp now under a
bridge in del rio texas where mostly
haitians gathered in the latest twist in
a months-long surge of migrants coming
to the u.s illegally right now in del
rio it is as if a hurricane has hit that
small town you know border patrol and
other law enforcement agencies are doing
everything they possibly can republican
congressman tony gonzalez has del rio in
his district and tells fox this is a
problem that is continuing to grow
continuing to spiral out of control and
expelling migrants that do not qualify
for asylum is part of that solution at
one point 15 000 haitians were huddled
together at the camp more than a
thousand though have been deported flown
back several thousand others taken into
custody and could also be deported that
has angered democrats like congresswoman
ayanna pressley haitian lives are black
lives and if we truly believe that black
lives matter the biden administration
must immediately halt all deportations
of haitian migrants the deportations
also upset the u.s special envoy to
haiti who resigned daniel foote said he
won't be associated with an inhumane
policy of sending haitians back to a
gang-controlled country white house
press secretary jensaki says there are
disagreements in these policy processes
that the president welcomes that the
secretary of state welcomes that that's
certainly a part of having discussions
and having robust discussions about the
best path forward gop congressman august
pfluger who visited the camp on saturday
told fox president biden getting
attacks from both sides of the aisle is
because he can't get a handle on this
situation you have a democratic mayor of
del rio mr lozano who has been crying
out for help the white house did not
detail what happened to thousands of
other haitians no longer at the camp
believed to have been allowed into the
u.s especially families and pregnant
women it's interesting because of what
there have been more than a million
people who have been apprehended by our
border patrol over the course of the by
the administration so far since last
january chris wallace is the anchor of
fox news sunday this experience at in
del rio the the flood of people coming
across that dam into del rio 15 000
people
huddled in unspeakable conditions under
the bridge now finding out that yes
we're sending some people back
particularly uh unaccompanied adults by
you know without families uh to haiti
but thousands more are being released
into the united states with a what's
called an npa a notice to appear in
immigration court some will some won't
it seems to me this is really galvanized
people it's just an image as opposed to
seeing you know little groups of people
coming across in the middle of the day
to see 15 000
people uh and
boy i think this this really
makes the point that the byte
administration
has had months to get a handle on this
and they haven't been unable to and it's
a tough political situation because on
the one hand there i think probably a
majority of the country is saying you
can't let
thousands of people many of whom may
have coveted uh come across the border
and settle in our country on the other
hand you have people on the left wing of
the democratic party saying you're
acting too much like trump when you
close the border and you deport some of
them so yeah you know the president is
feeling it
they failed to get a handle on it and it
really is catching up with him now and
the president's getting it from both
ends with as as you pointed out now the
other thing that happened with the
department of homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas he
for two days of testimony he couldn't
say exactly how many are being led in he
didn't seem to have the numbers and that
doesn't seem again it it gives the
creation it creates the notion that they
don't know or have a handle on it
well i don't know i suspect they know
they don't want to say because it would
be a bad number uh when when
the secretary of homeland security uh
alejandro mayorkas was asked uh at the
first hearing this week in the senate by
senator ron johnson and he said i don't
know
you know i thought he should have known
but okay he doesn't know he didn't come
with that piece of information but he
was going to have a hearing the very
next day in the house he was asked
exactly the same question and he
basically said i was too busy to find
out here's what he would have had to do
turn to his chief of staff on the ride
back from the first hearing and say get
me the number that's all you had to do
when he would have got a piece of paper
on his desk he it seems to me it was a
willful decision on his part i don't
want to put the number out there because
it's a number that's going to be
embarrassing to the administration
now
with the un general assembly this week
and the president there and all the
world leaders in new york
how do you think that's gone and and
afghanistan certainly is is a big issue
that it's hard for anyone to get a
handle on what to do with the taliban
right
well it it look it's it's not hard to
know who the taliban are they're a bunch
of thugs they're murderous they haven't
changed uh their behavior we're seeing
it already with the way they're
restricting
young women and and and girls from
leading the lives they were leaving
before they came in the problem is that
we need them at least at this point uh
not as allies we don't have to recognize
them but we can't uh you know cut them
off either because of the fact that
they're still
we don't know how many americans and we
do know tens of thousands of afghan
allies so it's a you know kind of uneasy
truth that we have with them and look if
they want to show that they're going to
be more tolerant towards women if they
want to show that they're going to help
us in the fight in terror against al
qaeda or isis k then let them
demonstrate that but in the meantime i
think we have to be
keep them very much at arm's length but
what about
having representation
as afghanistan's leadership at the u.n i
mean
that that
these are people that that we fought for
20 years and consider terrorists right
well yeah i i it seems to me from the
america's point of view it now i i
suppose the general assembly we don't
have a veto there we have a veto in the
security council i don't i don't know
whether we could stop it if the general
assembly wanted
it you know to admit them seems to me
it's awfully early let's wait and see
how they comport themselves what they do
in their country but you know two weeks
after they take over uh in a bloody
civil war uh i i don't know that we
should be recognizing anybody at this
point
now president biden's approval rating
continues to slip it's in the low 40s in
the latest gallup poll like 43
obviously that comes after what happened
with afghanistan and the troop
withdrawal and the evacuations and the
border crisis all that going on
is he in danger of slipping even more is
he losing independence
oh yeah i've been sure uh he's losing
democrats and independents some
republicans but he didn't have much to
lose there but you know he and he
doesn't really need the republicans but
independents and democrats absolutely
and you know this isn't just i mean in
terms of its impact on the midterm
elections i i wouldn't take that too
seriously that's more than a year from
now
you know a a million things can and will
happen but here's where it has a real
impact dave is is the president wants
democrats to take some tough votes now
on infrastructure and on the three and
what's now three and a half trillion
dollar tax and spending bill my guess is
it's gonna go down from there to to
under three but those are tough votes
you know on the one hand for moderates
it's too much money for
left-wingers it's too little money uh
it's a lot easier to hold your nose and
support a president if he's at 55
approval than if he's at 43 43 you want
to keep your distance from
which joe is more powerful right now in
your view the president or senator joe
manchin who seems to be guiding that
number will be guiding that number on on
the on the cost of this spending and
when we actually have a vote on it
well
you know look joe mansion is really
powerful but let's not put it all on him
there are other people he just frankly
wants to be out front but kirsten cinema
of arizona uh several of maggie hassan
of new hampshire there are a bunch of
democratic senators and again they can't
lose one they mean they have a zero
margin at 50 50. they got a they got to
have all of the democrats and then have
vice president harris break the tie any
of them could sink this and you know on
the other hand you've got bernie sanders
who's making it at least it's saying at
this point you know i'm not going to go
down to two trillion dollars i love the
fact that down to two trillion uh
because that isn't you know what we
agreed on
here's what i don't i understand i mean
if you're a democrat
in the senate or the house and i
understand you want to stand up the
moderates for their limits the democrats
for even more spending this is a
president and a party a governing party
that's in real trouble if you don't come
to an agreement yes nobody's going to be
satisfied but a compromise
uh and and you don't pass the
president's agenda what is that going to
that what is that going to do to
democrats in the midterm elections a
year from now i think that would be
disastrous i don't think they come back
from that so
you know i they don't they don't take
advice from me but i would say make a
deal
your both sides are going to have to
hold their nose but find something you
can live with and pass it because at
this point if you don't pass anything uh
you're going to be in the minority and
not able to pass anything in 2023.
you know we have this another we have so
many of these it's almost
like you don't even think about it
anymore but another potential government
shutdown the debt ceiling issue
republicans don't want to go along with
democrats on this because they say
they're being left out on the
reconciliation process
is it how serious is this one you think
this potential shutdown you know
you don't know uh i i can't imagine that
again
i think frankly the the republicans are
being hypocritical in saying they won't
vote for raising the debt ceiling a lot
of what they're raising the debt ceiling
for is spending that was approved under
president trump it's not like this is
all
uh money that was approved under
president biden so and the democrats
helped raise the debt ceiling when
president trump was approving big
spending having said that you know mitch
mcconnell the senate republican leader
has made it clear they're not going to
vote
for a debt ceiling uh
if the democrats are going to go ahead
with three and a half trillion dollars
of spending on other things
you know i don't think it's particularly
fair but the democrats do have a way
certainly at this point to uh to
fund the government and avoid a
government shutdown
and it seems to me that you just go
ahead and do that without the debt
ceiling uh because otherwise we run out
of money but i guess the next next week
next uh thursday the 30th
last uh question chris obviously you're
getting ready for fox news sunday who's
going to be on this time
well i don't know yet we know we're
going to be covering the border we know
we're going to be covering the budget
crisis but uh these days uh booking
guests uh in washington a little bit
like herding cats so we'll see you know
uh it'll be a great show and while i'm
at it and plugging things countdown bin
laden number two in the new york times
bestseller list it's a history thriller
you think you know the story but uh i
promise you there are surprises on every
page
well we'll be uh looking forward to fox
news sunday and also uh i i can't wait
to read the book because i loved your uh
your countdown to in 1945 on the nuclear
bombs uh back in
japan so i look forward to looking at
that uh chris wallace anchor of fox news
sunday thank you so much for joining us
thank you dave
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
natalie browning just was not getting
married without having her grandpa as
her first dance partner the problem was
natalie lives in virginia and her 94
year old grandfather nelson may lives in
florida his plans to attend her wedding
in june were cancelled after he had a
stroke two weeks before the big day
natalie and her husband got married in
late june but on august 1st she boarded
a plane and traveled 800 miles to see
her grandpa with her she carried her
wedding dress in a pink garment bag did
her makeup at the airport then when she
got to his house changed into the dress
and had that long-awaited dance with her
grandfather
natalie who is a jeweler says her
business is centered around reminding
people that they're valuable she said
making their dream of the shared dance
happen is one of the ways she's doing
that in her own life tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fala
what's on your mind so joe biden's
approval rate in the crucial swing state
of iowa has fallen to 31
31
folks i don't take any joy in saying
this because i root for the president no
matter who it is but if this were a
baseball game we'd be putting in a
relief pitcher by now luckily for joe
the only reliever we can bring in is
kamala harris and she's about as popular
as a traffic jam i mention traffic
because not only is biden botched the
border and embarrassed us in afghanistan
but his refusal to stick with trump
policies that made us energy independent
has led to a historic surge in gas
prices right now as we speak the
national cost of gas is 320 a gallon
that absolutely crushes taxi drivers and
truckers and anyone else who drives a
car not to mention all of my friends who
sniff gas i wish i was kidding but at
this point the only thing anyone smells
is the dumpster fire burning in our oval
office joe biden was sold to us as a
stabilizing force after four years of
donald trump we probably should have
held on to the receipt i'm jimmy fallon
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes